um i wanted to ask you about something
specific that i just wanted to get your
take on
and that's the six nine situation he
just was out in l.a
yeah for like three or four days
obviously
just out here being very disrespectful
um trolling the [ __ ] out of everybody
um he pulled up to nipsey's um
memorial you know development next
nipsey store
um i had heard well first of all
you know what are your what is your take
on like
on that specific like like him coming
out to la and kind of just showing out i
know he's got
and then i wanted to ask you a follow-up
dude i just wanted to get your initial
kind of perception
it's expected for
dudes who are looking for
the limelight
promotional tactic and stunts are
heavy
real [ __ ] don't move like
[ __ ] real [ __ ] move like real
[ __ ] move so
that situation to me is all about
numbers it's all about promotion
it's all about controversy and when you
got them three things
you'll stay in a motherfucker's mouth
all day exactly whether it's good or
bad they don't give a [ __ ] i've always
been told
promotion is promotion whether it's good
or bad
[ __ ] is talking about you yeah
there's that cliche
oh there's no such thing as bad press
none none
so unless you're tory lanez anyway
continue so look
he comes out and he's the talk of the
town
now nobody's really
real [ __ ] i'm not worried about that
situation
you got a lot of [ __ ] people
who feel
that it's disrespectful whatever
whatever
but on a real day he's not going to do
that type of [ __ ]
knowing that his real [ __ ] standing
ground i heard he did that at like seven
in the morning
of course you do it like i said it's all
publicity
and i like i said i don't have nothing
to say about dude
dude do what he do he trying to make his
money that's his thing
it's all about the money let's let's
face it it's all about the money with
certain cats
it's not about being you know loyal or
true or whatever
so i don't understand why a lot of
[ __ ] are tripping
off of the cat because it's all been
that
gimmicky situation from the game that's
what he does from the gate
so don't be shocked by the antics
you get me it's just like a [ __ ]
who want to promote a movie and go
downtown and skydive off of the tallest
building or tight rope across or
anything for promotion is to keep a
motherfucker's name
in in people's mouths because the
quieted
you are and you don't talk about it
[ __ ] don't die away in the wind
so i have to keep my name in the public
so you do certain [ __ ] you do dumb [ __ ]
yeah i was gonna say because with with
someone like him coming to la obviously
he's got a lot of security of course um
i'm not sure if he had like had to pay
for any protection out here or not
um but do you think that like i have
a lot of people i know i've spoken with
a lot of a lot of uh
homies that are are from out here who
are you know some g's that like
like six nine kind of like do you think
he kind of cracked the street code or
maybe just
i think he's the first person to like do
what he's doing
openly there's been other snitches that
are of course of course
people but like for him to be so outward
with it do you think he kind of
cracked the the street code and and you
think
that like there's a way to move forward
where
because the snitch thing has always been
that one code that
is the unbreakable thing right right
he's still successful he's calling
people out like i mean it's it's
it's it's kind of crazy but y'all but
you have to understand the snitch code
the snitch code stands for real [ __ ]
right it only stands for real [ __ ]
being glasses alone talked about that
like if you're like a civilian if you're
a no
if you're not mixed up in [ __ ] you you
should snitch
and then like if if something happens to
you right you're a normal person
right or the police but if you're you
know g malone
like nah i'm not calling the police i'ma
handle my [ __ ] the way i handle my [ __ ]
because that because because i
this is my life exactly your reputation
is your life exact state and your word
is at stake
but why are
so like adamant to
put the snitch jacket on [ __ ]
who never was real from the first place
that's where you getting [ __ ] confused
don't give a [ __ ] is stop looking at the
money
the chains the [ __ ] streams
and all that stop looking at that [ __ ] a
[ __ ] was never
real from negate so how can you put the
code of you should follow it why because
a [ __ ] was hanging with street
[ __ ]
and because a [ __ ] was rapping
what and they allowed that guy to be
around him now i mean
if you gonna pay a [ __ ] then
fine if they gonna you know i
and this is coming from the [ __ ]
hell yeah we gonna let that [ __ ] hang
around us if he kicking up 150
200 grand we you think we not
[ __ ] come hang
right we benefiting from that right
everyone's getting paid
okay but you gotta understand
when you put a [ __ ] situation
and he's not
real from the gate it's gonna backfire
he's gonna tell on you i mean are you
surprised
you shouldn't be you get me
just like with with with my man george
floyd
and the police brutality [ __ ]
been doing that [ __ ] forever
it's on video now okay and i get it and
it's [ __ ] up that
my boy had to lose his life in that
situation
but you shouldn't be surprised
and that's what gets me sometimes is
when [ __ ] go oh no i can't
believe it
how you how you can't this [ __ ] just
happened last week around the corner but
it wasn't on film
[ __ ] never been real never
let me tell you something and this has
been going on since
hip-hop and money has been around the
more money you got
the more [ __ ] courageous you feel and
that go with every [ __ ] rapper
i don't give a [ __ ] if you a street
rapper
and whether you a real [ __ ] or
you was the poindexter [ __ ]
in the crew the minute you get bread in
your pocket and chains and
whatever and you [ __ ] a couple of
[ __ ] you gonna start feeling like
mighty man
i'm untouchable i'm the hardest [ __ ] on
the block i'm the hardest [ __ ] but the
first time a [ __ ] tests your hardness
you fold and you're gonna tell so
we shouldn't be confused by the fact of
what that situation is
you shouldn't he's not
he's not a a a nigga's rapper he's not
my rapper he's not you're a rapper he's
not whatever no he's like 13 year old
kids who like tic toc
thank you yeah okay don't get it
confused because a lot of [ __ ]
are going so what he told
so what that's your kid in there
vouching for him
because let me tell you if you're a
grown ass [ __ ] and you banging
that [ __ ]
something is physically wrong yeah
something is physically wrong
now i get it the little
the little girls the little the strip
club girls who dance into his music
and the little kids who like the
colorful and the hair and
i get it i get it but
let's not be confused for a dude like me
or a nip or you or whoever
it's not my music hell no so
let's not get confused about who
vouchers for
my man you gave me a lot of youth a lot
of [ __ ] a lot of kids
bumped that and that's where you know
because
you pick up your phone as a 15 year old
kid
and go bingo
because me as a grown ass man i'm not
picking up my phone going i'm finna
download this [ __ ] and bump it in my car
right right right it's for the so you
you have to
you you have to understand what the
situation is and that's what i say about
that
disrespectful yeah
but you probably should expect that from
those type of [ __ ]